mit einer knusprigen panade lassen sich
teure zutaten lukrativ strecken
sebastian lee geprüft welche marken
hersteller besonders gerne an fisch
fleisch und käse sparen und zeigt wo das
profi paniermehl eigentlich herkommt
[Musik]
die spur der industrie panade für
sebastian ins rheinland nach neuss
denn dieser anlage wird ein spezial brot
gebacken das niemals beim bäcker landet
jede menge teig wird hier produziert
denn profi paniermehl wird nicht wie zu
hause aus altem brot oder brötchen
gemacht
[Musik]
eine rot-schwarze mit über 3.000 tonnen
paniermehl im monat ist die firma brater
europas größter hersteller
[Musik]
drinstecken einfache zutaten mehl wasser
salz und hefe
nach dem backen wird das brot maschinell
verteilt
ja das ist weiß
darauf kommt nicht nur auf den geschmack
an wichtig ist auch die farbe des brösel
brotes dafür sorgt hier ein exotisches
gewürz
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt kurkuma das ist dafür da
dass derzeit nachher gelb wird und
später an richtig schön goldene
schnitzel oder genau kurkuma auch
gelbwurz genannt stammt aus südasien zu
pulver gemahlen sorgt sie für eine
kräftige farbe ideal für die goldbraune
optik weiteres plus panierte schnitzel
etwa bleiben beim braten saftiger als
und panierte
[Musik]
durch die einfachen zutaten und schnelle
herstellung ist kann e mail ein sehr
günstiges produkt die ideale zutat für
tricks
[Musik]
schön gelb wird schön gold und frischer
geht's nicht das früheste alte brot
wasser namen kann gerade zwei stunden
alt
doch welche neuen produkte mit
paniermehl lassen sich noch entwickeln
eine frage der markus wiesendahl in
seinem test labor nach geht hier tüftelt
er an rezepten für die industrie
sebastian liege hat da eine idee eine
kleine challandes mitgebracht
ein neuer profitabler knusprig das
problem ähnlich wie calamari ringe haben
gurken eine feste glatte oberfläche
paniermehl bleibt da schlecht haften
damit es trotzdem klappt setzt markus
wiesendahl auf eine geheimwaffe namens
naspa nadel
[Musik]
da haben wir spezielle maile und stärken
drin aber die details kann ich natürlich
dazu nicht verraten
in verbindung mit wasser entsteht aus
den stärkemehl mischung eine art
klebstoff auf teurer wie wir sie zu
hause nehmen kann die industrie so
verzichten
auf mainzer einmal oder zweimal parieren
doch ins offene wasser doppelt so feucht
[Musik]
stark wasserhaltige lebensmittel wie
sebastians gurken werden generell
zweimal paniert denn nur so entsteht ein
knuspriger mantel um den feuchten kern
ohne durchzuweichen abpfiff
jetzt zeigt sich ob die panade auch an
den glatten feuchten gewürzgurken haften
bleibt
[Musik]
die sind hier die gut aus die optik
stimmt aber schmeckt der snack auch wie
erhofft nur dann lässt er sich auch
vermarkten
[Musik]
das schmeckt also ich würd mal sagen für
acht stück nicht mehr drauf 50 na dann
oder morgen gleich weitermachen oder die
glöckchen millionäre sind geboren
sebastians rechnung ist zwar fiktiv aber
nicht unrealistisch
in amerika sind frittierte guten sogar
schon ein hit die industrie weiß
jedenfalls längst mit panade macht man
prophet beispiel camembert pur kostete
im schnitt sechs euro pro kilo paniert
zweieinhalb mal soviel 15 euro und auch
alaska seelachs lässt sich verbeugen und
paniert liegt das kilo bei knapp 5 euro
mit knuspern mantel zahlt man mehr als
das doppelte watte preisaufschläge für
ein bisschen paniermehl und das bisschen
ist manchmal ganz schön viel
[Musik]
warum man gucken wie viel panade auf dem
produkt so drauf ist
produktentwickler sebastian lege beginnt
mit dem beliebtesten stück fleisch der
deutschen dem schnitzel
dass man hier so richtig schön erkennen
kann weil das industriell prämierten
produkte in diese kleine rillen hier
sorgen dafür damit die panade schön
offen bleibt und so eine rolle fällt
auch immer ein körnchen mehr vor dem
guten günstigen zeug
die fertig schnitzel von edeka können
sich dennoch sehen lassen
das fleisch macht in unserer stichprobe
fast drei viertel des produkt gewichts
aus der panade anteil beträgt 26 prozent
beim altenheim back camembert sieht es
schon kritischer aus
grob zwei drittel käse ein drittel
panade
[Musik]
und beim klassiker auf dem kinderteller
mal sehen was und fischstäbchen mit
banale liegt 29 8 gramm
das pulver die panade ab und sehen mal
wie viel schüchterner noch übrig bleibt
hersteller verspricht saftiges
seelachsfilet knusprig frittieren noch
ein zwei kümmerliche diana seite legen
aber zwölf gramm panade für ein
fischstäbchen wiegt man alle stäbchen
kommt man auf einen fisch anteil von 65
prozent
auch hier also gut zwei drittel produkt
ein drittel panade
[Musik]
doch wie steht es um die back
fischstäbchen von iglo mit 100% viel
drauf ich habe hier 11 5 gramm fisch
gelegt jetzt legen wir den bock mehr
drauf
[Musik]
ist das der knaller 16,7 gramm backteig
gerade mal 49 fischfilet das billige
drumherum macht über die hälfte des
gewichts aus
[Musik]
deswegen fällt die dekoration auch so
aus buck fischstäbchen
da kommt erst der backtag und an der
fisch ärgerlich für die verbraucher aber
völlig legal
die backteig version ist sogar teurer
als klassische fischstäbchen
der trick mit der panade für die
industrie ein lohnendes geschäft in
unserem vergleich schneidet das
schnitzel am besten ab es enthält am
wenigsten panade back käse und die
meisten fischprodukte liegen im
mittelfeld back fischstäbchen und
chicken nuggets sind die schlusslichter
viel panade wenig vom wertvollen inhalt
natürlich können die hersteller mit
einem hohen anteil an panade viel geld
sparen indem sie weniger von der wert
geben eine zutat einsetzen
hier ist es für den verbraucher immer
wichtig zu kontrollieren wie viel
fleisch fisch oder käse steckt
eigentlich unter meiner panade um dann
herauszufinden welches produkt möchte
ich kaufen
die hersteller sind verpflichtet die
anteile auf der zutatenliste auszuweisen
wer sicher gehen will dem hilft der
blick auf die verpackung leckeres guilty
pleasure oder überteuert und ungesund
wie steht ihr zu panierten
fertigprodukten schreibt es uns in die
kommentare
und wo es die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser esser